there's now a lot of content on the khan
academy so i thought i would give you a
quick overview video of how to think
about the playlists so the most basic
playlist is the arithmetic playlist
arithmetic and this is it literally
starts at one plus one equals two and it
moves about as far as operations on
decimals long division things like that
the next most advanced playlist is
pre-algebra and if you're starting from
scratch you might want to go in this
order
pre-algebra
and pre-algebra as the name implies
covers a lot of the foundational
concepts for algebra like adding
subtracting multiplying dividing
negative numbers and fractions and
exponents and then we have several
playlists that address actual algebra so
there's an algebra playlist
there is an algebra playlist there is an
algebra 1 playlist
algebra
one playlist and then there is a
there is a california california
standards
california standards and there's two
playlists california standards algebra 1
and california standards algebra 2.
this
just algebra playlist this is the the i
would call this kind of the main
playlist covering algebra when i just
make an arbitrary algebra video i put in
this playlist and i try to put it in
order of of of of of i guess advancement
or of difficulty this starts at the most
basic algebraic equations
but with one caveat that the the first
few videos in this place are old videos
these are some of the very first videos
that i did when i started making youtube
videos and so they're not in hd they're
kind of rough i'm using microsoft paint
uh they're not the the smoothest videos
on the planet but then obviously it also
has a lot of new videos in this and this
algebra playlist it covers both algebra
1 and algebra 2. and i merged it into
one playlist because because frankly
algebra 2 has a lot of overlap or a lot
of review with algebra 1.
this algebra 1 playlist this is worked
examples from ck12.org
ck12.org open source algebra 1 book
which is
fairly comprehensive for covering the
california standards and for those of
you who aren't in california what i say
is
this is fairly comprehensive for algebra
1 and if you know algebra 1 by these
standards you're probably going to know
the great majority of what you didn't
know
wherever you might be taking algebra and
frankly if you watch both of these
playlists i'm pretty sure you're going
to be able to do any type of algebra
problem that you might see in any
curriculum math is math now this is
worked examples but you can and it's all
done recently so all of these videos are
of a fairly good quality and they're all
in in high definition and you could just
watch this algebra 1 playlist in order
and i'll just give you a little bit of
warning the first 16 videos 16 videos
the very first ones are kind of an
overview so they move a little bit
faster so if you have a little bit if
you're seeing algebra for the first time
and they seem like they're moving a
little quickly that's just because
they're giving a survey of the of the
course and that's why
and i did that just because that was the
order that it that it was displayed in
the book but then after those first 16
videos starting with one step equations
it actually goes at a very moderate pace
and i do a lot of examples and explain
the concepts as i do the examples
so if you're just starting off want to
learn algebra one i i recommend
reviewing pre-algebra it never hurts but
then these are the two core algebra
playlists and you could start in either
one and just find where you where you
feel comfortable i would recommend if
you're someplace in between you know a
little bit of algebra start at the
beginning watch every video in both of
these playlists if something is just
super duper easy to you then you move on
to the next video but just make sure
that you have all of your bases covered
now these these videos right these
playlists right here the california
standards these are just worked examples
based on the california standards so
after watching these you want to see
more examples it'll never hurt to watch
these two playlists right there now once
you're done with algebra
you might want to look at the geometry
playlist
you could probably start on the geometry
playlist just with pre-algebra but it's
good to have that algebraic
foundation there
and in most school systems you take
algebra 1 first then geometry then
algebra 2. so this is just a recommended
path you might want to take and then
after geometry you're ready to move into
trigonometry
and after algebra you're also ready to
move because this playlist as i said it
goes through algebra two after this
you're also ready for precalculus
you're also ready for precalculus and
i'll write it at the same level as
trigonometry because in most
in most school systems you take
trigonometry and precalculus in the same
year usually your junior or your senior
year
and then obviously after pre-calculus
and trigonometry
the next you're now ready for calculus
and this is a fairly extensive playlist
it covers calculus one two
and three so differential integral and
multivariable and vector calculus so in
some places even you could all almost
say even through calculus four now we
have another
another playlist that has the word
algebra in it but it is a much more
advanced algebra even though it might
sound like a simpler algebra it's called
linear algebra
and if you've never seen algebra before
do not watch this playlist it might
sound like hey linear algebra is easier
than non-linear algebra no this is a a
mathematically rigorous
course that normally math and
engineering majors take in their
probably their sophomore year of college
and i would say that you could start off
if you have just basic understanding of
precalculus you could probably
you could probably start the linear
algebra playlist but i would recommend
being a fairly sophisticated
mathematically you probably want a
little bit of your calculus out of the
way to start it even though it is it is
really algebra it is mathematically more
sophisticated than a lot of what goes on
in the calculus playlist and on the
calculus playlist once you're about
halfway through you don't have to go
through the whole playlist you're then
ready for another advanced playlist that
we have and that's differential
equations
differential
equations probably two-thirds of the way
through the calculus playlist you're
probably then ready for differential
equations another
usually sophomore level course for math
and science and engineering majors
now everything else we have some we have
some probability and statistics algebra
is all you really need for that but i'll
put it here because it's reasonably
advanced probability
there's a probability playlist
probability
and then there is a statistics playlist
and they are obviously related you might
want to do the probability one first but
you don't have to
there's a probability and there is a
statistics
statistics playlist we also have a
california standards geometry playlist
and that's worked examples just like
that one over there so i'll do that like
that we also have
california
standards
california standards geometry
so you could you could look at that if
you want to see more
geometric
worked examples and then when you think
about the sciences we have physics and
the physics playlist is mainly i call
them applied algebra problems so you
might want to watch physics right around
after you finish algebra
there's a there's only a few videos that
require calculus i'll eventually make a
entire playlist on calculus based
physics most of this is just
algebra-based physics so you're ready to
go if you have a good solid
understanding of algebra and then the
other science is the chemistry uh it'd
be nice to have kem have algebra out of
the way pre-algebra is probably enough
for most of it pre-algebra is probably
enough for most of it but algebra if you
have your algebra out of the way then
you're going to have no trouble at all
with the chemistry playlist
chemistry and then biology does deal
with a little bit of of probability and
things like that so it wouldn't hurt but
that's actually that doesn't even
require too much mathematics or at least
the mathematics that i've diagrammed
here we could put biology here
i guess the big takeaway is that algebra
is really important for pretty much
anything you want to do there are some
genetics problems that require some
basic level and and some population
genetics population
genetics problems that have some biology
in it and then all the finance and
economics that also i think it assumes a
base level of algebraic understanding so
the things on banking
the things on banking you don't have to
have a super advance if you just go
maybe a halfway through one of these
playlists you're probably ready for
these banking economics
economics
and finance so hopefully that gives you
a good overview of everything that's on
the khan academy and let me know if you
have any questions